a bombshell report about the beep State
John Solomon listen to this explosive
story out from the hill tonight a
convenient omission Trump campaign
advisor denied collusion to FBI source
early on now it's about the FBI ignoring
exculpatory evidence in their FISA
warrant applications John Solomon joins
us along with former Trump campaign aide
George papadopolis his wife Simona who
fought so hard for his defense John I'll
let you break it down sure oh yeah this
is really simple remember the FBI opened
up the entire Trump collusion
investigation on the suspicion that
George had some collusion going on
behind the scenes with the Russians
specifically related to Hillary
Clinton's emails in the hacking just a
few weeks after they opened that
investigation George has a conversation
with an FBI informant a professor named
Hal perm in London and he tells Halperin
he's going to tell it way better than I
am but he tells him we weren't colluding
I wasn't interested in fact colluding
with the Russians would be treason we
didn't do it the FBI has that in his
possession
it's obligation he's either to shut down
the investigation or find other evidence
what do they do they don't tell the
court about this they leave this out of
the FISA application and they pivot to
the steel dossier and other things which
are far less credible in their own minds
in the original allegation about George
and so this is really it's it's evidence
of innocence withheld from the court
without from the American sounds like
Huysmans history and don't forget fraud
was committed on the FISA Court four
times because they purposely withheld
where the information came from bought
and paid for by Hillary and they
withheld from the court the bulk of
evidence was the unverified
uncorroborated dossier
simona you went to bat for your husband
when he couldn't speak for himself
you know I hate to say now remember Lisa
pate said there's no evidence nine
months that's when they started their
leak strategy their insurance policy and
remember struck said there's no there
there even they said it and yet they
used lie about him that's what I try to
stress so since that day number one I am
a direct witness of what happened to
George
from Europe and I know the background
and from Italy Italy exactly not Russian
people said I know what people write
that all the time I don't know I can try
to spaghetti
anyway so I insisted there were so many
exculpatory evidence is and that's why
you hosted me kindly in the first show
and I said I really wish that it would
come out because I know it's the
sentences has been fair but I think he
doesn't deserve look I would say don't
open your case up because two weeks
anybody can suck up two weeks of their
life and I wouldn't want you to open
yourself up to something further so
you're in a tough spot but this was what
John's reporting is true anything you
can add well all I can add about this is
that John is absolutely right I actually
have zero Russia contacts or connections
whatsoever
from after a year of researching my
situation and John's excellent reporting
it seems that I was completely set up by
Western intelligence masquerading as
Russians now if that's true
and certain people in our intelligence
community knew it the whole time that
these people that I encountered were
actually Western intelligence and not
Russians
what on earth am I getting in trouble
for it I said from the beginning you
didn't have it that's what John say
absolutely I told this person stuff in
hopper you know just stay away from me
and and he said it and that's apparently
exactly what happened yeah John
where do we go with this what should
what does he do here I mean John I got
to tell you this tonight the spin coming
out of the Justice Department is
absolutely amazing I would call it on
American people are telling me tonight
they don't think the Justice Department
had an obligation to tell the courts
about exculpatory information well think
about yeah and in the FISA Court were
the accused someone like George doesn't
have a representative a lawyer to defend
them it's all in secret can you imagine
that sentiment being shared with
Congress or to the judges on the FISA
Court I'd like to see how long that
lasts what do you do after this we're
just looking to move on with our lives
right now and start a family you're
gonna and you're gonna go after people
that have mistreated you anybody
administrated me I'm going out for I'm
gonna see Gowdy and Goodlatte this week
in a couple days we want the truth out
there okay she really fought for you
congratulations I love her the death
good for you I don't think so